I read this character and I went okay I
said this is fun I said do you mind Ben
I want to play this character I said I
want to have fat hands and I want to
dance
[Applause]
he looked at me he's like what I take
dance classes and I took hip-hop classes
and then what I'll find is I'll find a
character to put that with so I said
look I just I don't know what to say
like sometimes with a character you just
get an instinct on what you want to do
and I I just know I really want fat
hands and I'm going to dance okay
flaming Dragon [ __ ] face first take a
big step back and literally [ __ ] your
own face he said look are you sure you
can you why don't you just be you it
just looks at me like uh you know that
men look we're like okay like I don't
know what is it what what's happening
here yeah yeah he created the makeup and
we did the makeup test he was La he like
he picked the music out he edited this
thing together he was just pissing
himself he sent it to me he's like okay
I get it I get it yeah